HAVE YOU TOTALLY UNPRINCIPLED
PEOPLE WITH YOU UP THERE.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU.
ON THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE IS DEMOCRAT ADAM
SCHIFF OF CALIFORNIA.
HE ACCUSED US OF BEING AGENTS OF
VLADAMIR PUTIN.
LOOK INTO THE CAMERA AND SAY FOR
A FACT I KNOW THE GOVERNMENT OF
VLADAMIR PUTIN WAS BEHIND THE
HACKS OF PODESTA.
>> I KNOW IT FOR A FACT --
>> Tucker: OF JOHN PODESTA'S
E-MAILS.
HACKED JOHN PODESTA'S E-MAIL.
>> YOU'RE CARRYING WATER FOR THE
KREMLIN.
SAY THEY HACKED --
>> YOU'LL HAVE TO MOVE YOUR SHOW
TO RUSSIAN TELEVISION.
>> Tucker: THAT'S SO BENEATH
YOUR OFFICE BECAUSE IT'S SO DUMB
AND YOU'RE BEING DUE PLIS  -- WE
KNOW FOR A FACT THE GOVERNMENT
DID AND THAT YOU'RE HIDING
BEHIND WEASEL WORDS.
>> Tucker: THAT GUY'S A LIAR AND
DEMAGOGUE.
WE HAVE A COLUMNIST FOR THE WALL
STREET JOURNAL ASKING ABOUT THE
TRUMP DOSSIER.
THANK YOU.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SO I'M ANNOYED BY
ADAM SCHIFF.
YOU HAVE AN EMOTIONAL DISTANCE
FROM THIS.
TELL US YOUR CONCERN ABOUT HIS
BEHAVIOR AS A MEMBER OF THE
INTEL COMMITTEE.
>> THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IS
AN OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE AND
THEY'RE CHARGED WITH GETTING
INFORMATION, KEEPING TABS ON THE
GOVERNMENT.
THIS MAN SEEMS DETERMINED NOT TO
GET INFORMATION AND CERTAINLY
NOT TO GET IT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WHEN THE REPUBLICANS PUT
TOGETHER THEIR MEMO OUTLINING
SOME OF THE INFORMATION THEY
FOUND FROM THE FISA APPLICATION
AND SO FORTH, HE WAS ASKED ON
CNN SHOULDN'T THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SEE THIS AND OFFERED FOR
THE TRUTH.
HE DOESN'T TRUST THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE BIAS IS TOWARDS DISCLOSURE.
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE THINGS THAT
SHOULD NOT BE DISCLOSED BUT WE
TIME.
REMEMBER, HE FOUGHT THE
HE FOUGHT THE SUBPOENA FOR
FUSION THAT LED TO THE NEWS THAT
THE HILARY CAMPAIGN FUNDED THE
DOSSIER.
>> Tucker: IT WAS DEMOCRATS,
FRANK CHURCH OF IDAHO, FOR
EXAMPLE, ARGUING THE PUBLIC
DESERVES THE BROAD OUTLINE OF
WHAT THE LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
DOING AND IT'S OUR COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW.
DEMOCRATS USED TO SAY THAT ALL
THE TIME.
WHEN DID THEY STOP AND WHY?
I WANT TO KNOW WHETHER PEOPLE ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH
RUSSIA AND IF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES PUT THEIR
FINGER ON THE SCALE FOR
POLITICAL REASONS.
BOTH CANDIDATES WERE UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR SOME REASON BY
THE FBI.
IT'S EXTRAORDINARY.
IT'S FINDING OUT THE TRUTH AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE -- WHEN
THE MEMO WAS PRODUCED AND IT
CAME OUT IT HAD THE #RELEASE THE
MEMO.
CONGRESSMAN SCHIFF WAS BLAMING
RUSSIAN BOX IS MORE FOR
DISCLOSURE THAN A CONGRESSMAN ON
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE.
>> Tucker: WE'VE INVITED HIM
MANY TIME TO COME ON AND EXPLAIN
THAT AND HOW HE FOUND HIMSELF
BASICALLY PRACTICING McARTHYISM.
>> HE'S ALWAYS ON THE TV SAYING
HE FOUND MORE THAN
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE O.J.'S PROMISE TO
FIND THE REAL KILLER.
>> Tucker: HE HASN'T BEEN HERE